you i've never seen the river as low as
this stephan marty tells me he's a
fisheries officer
in a normal year the level of the goron
here would be above our heads the river
cuts through toulouse it's the city's
lifeblood providing drinking water
irrigating farmland and cooling a
nuclear plant
stefan has had to take fish out of the
river and put them into special tanks
because the water is too warm
it's complicated everything is connected
there will be less snow in the mountains
the glaciers will melt sooner this year
there has been much less snow so less
water in the mountain lakes so pumping
of the lakes is lower to keep the water
longer over three weeks forty percent of
the water held in reserve in
hydroelectric dams in the pyrenees
mountains has been released into the
gueron to keep it flowing
just
heat waves in europe are increasing at a
faster rate than almost anywhere else on
the planet and global warming increases
the likelihood of drought drying out
soils and vegetation
minimum sources
we need 60 millimeters of rainfall to be
able to replant the soil christelle
carpentier tells me
the forecast is for three millimeters
this week
it's not enough
[Laughter]
the corn harvest across france is
expected to be 18 and a half percent
lower this year than last there's
already a global shortage because of the
war in ukraine
even the sunflowers have turned away
from the scorching sun
where there is access to water there
isn't enough to go around christelle
says she'll lose more than 30 percent of
her crop this year
if we don't get enough water in this
region there will be no viable
agriculture even today the cattle
farmers here have no grass on their
fields today we are on a land where it's
crucial to develop irrigation if only to
be able to achieve minimum profitability
france's worst drought since records
began in 1958 has affected so many
aspects of how people live here and i
think we will
we will walk a lot
we will uh
train the kayak and we will walk because
there is not enough water for for the
floating
in july rainfall across france was down
84 compared to normal according to the
french weather service
the summer isn't over yet
now every part of france is under some
sort of water restrictions and
two-thirds of all departments are at the
peak crisis level and one of the
concerns is that underground water
tables are also running unusually low
because they aren't being replenished
with rain water so they really need it
to rain nick yeah industry needed right
across europe pat bernard thanks for
that spanish smith report